this is a when over productions video
made possible by video blocks get an
exclusive seven day free trial of video
blocks with up to a hundred and forty
free stock footage clips for your videos
by using the linked video blocks comm
slash future before I start I want to
quickly mention that I started a podcast
with Brian from real engineering called
show makers in the very first episode
which is out now we chat with none other
than Hank green I'd really appreciate it
if you give it a try and the link is
down in description trains are expensive
so expensive in fact down three of the
most traveled routes in three countries
New York to Washington in the u.s.
Edinburgh to London in the UK and Paris
de Leon in France they're pretty much
the same price as the plane these routes
start at $49 thirty pounds and thirty
euros respectively on the train and $52
thirteen pounds and 53 euros on the
plane on a longer route like New York to
Chicago the difference is even more
pronounced fifty nine dollars for the
plane 108 for the Train and that's
keeping in mind that trains are
subsidized or government-run in almost
every country while airlines are highly
profitable commercial enterprises the
planes flying between DC and New York
are forty nine million dollar machines
while the trains traveling the route
cost no more than ten million total the
plane has to burn 1.7 gallons of fuel
per mile flown while the Train relies on
clean electric power all this therefore
begs the question why are trains so
expensive now I mentioned that fares
between DC and New York start at $49
that's far from the average price
seventy three dollars let's look at the
expenses that go into that fare the
single largest expense for Amtrak is
staffing trains require a lot of people
to operate eighty five thousand
passengers journey on Amtrak daily but
for that Amtrak employs 20,000 people
meaning that daily Amtrak requires one
employee for every four passengers on
top of that the majority of those
working for Amtrak are highly
specialized unionized workers who demand
high salaries Amtrak financial reports
tell us that they spend
105 thousand dollars per employee but
that's not to say that everyone at
Amtrak is making six figures taxes and
benefits typically cost an employer
thirty to forty percent of a salary so
the actual average salary for an Amtrak
employee is around seventy-five thousand
dollars these salary costs are so high
that they account for over a third of
the ticket price between DC and New York
twenty-five dollars and 82 cents total
the cost of employees is so high for
train operators largely because trains
are so slow for a flight from DC to New
York an airline would only have to pay
employees for an hour of work while
Amtrak has to pay their employees for
three and a half hours of work the
difference is even more striking on the
long-haul routes Chicago to Los Angeles
for example an airline would have to pay
for four hours of work while Amtrak pays
for forty four hours of work in addition
trains have physical infrastructure to
maintain along the journey the rails
airlines also have infrastructure to pay
for on each end the airports but between
those they just use the sky which is
free
Amtrak only owns seven hundred and
thirty miles of those twenty-one
thousand miles of track they use but
they still indirectly pay for the
employees who maintain those twenty
thousand miles of rented track through
the fees charged by the track owners for
their use the next largest cost for
train operators is that of the trains
themselves trains are that expensive
compared to airplanes but they still
cost millions of dollars
the locomotive pulling the train from DC
to New York cost six point five million
dollars and then each one of the
passenger cars cost an additional four
hundred thousand dollars with a seven
car train that works out to nine point
four million dollars which accounts for
9.60 seven cents on this particular
ticket the other part of infrastructure
rails costs and track an additional
$3.66 on this ticket railroad tracks are
extraordinarily expensive to build
typically more than $1,000,000 per mile
but on routes like DC to New York
they're just used so much that the per
train or per ticket costs is negligible
Amtrak is a business so it also needs to
pay to run the business two dollars and
15 cents of its ticket
- administrative costs and then another
$1 and 31 cents to advertising moving on
trains are extremely safe compared to
cars but you're still more than three
times as likely to be killed on or by a
train than a plane trains do
occasionally crash and they also crash
into people when this happens
Amtrak often has to pay a settlement to
the victims and the fees associated with
that account for 79 cents on the DC to
New York ticket that does mean that when
traveling between DC and New York in
essence you're paying 79 cents in order
for Amtrak to kill or injure people
those were all the major costs to run a
train but there's still another $5 and
91 cents on that ticket that just
represents other minor costs so the
total expense for Amtrak to run that
train is 50 dollars and 14 cents
the remaining $22 and 86 cents is pure
profit you see the train from DC to New
York the Northeast Regional is one of
the few Amtrak routes to make a profit
the demand speed and frequency of the
train helps it succeed financially where
other routes fail per passenger per mile
Amtrak makes eight cents a profit on the
Northeast Regional the low-speed train
and 29 cents per passenger mile on the
Acela Express the high-speed train these
profitable routes help pay for Amtrak's
unprofitable routes and there are a lot
of them some routes like the Sunset
Limited between New Orleans and Los
Angeles lose as many as twenty one point
seven cents per passenger per mile and
when passengers can travel 2,000 miles
on that route that's a lot of loss as I
mentioned that $49 fare is not the
average ticket price to travel between
DC and New York the $49 fare is the
price at which Amtrak starts selling
tickets but as the date of travel nears
the price can increase to hundreds of
dollars that might seem like price
gouging but it's actually a way to make
sure everyone can afford a ticket that's
not to say Amtrak and other train
companies are these altruistic
organizations trying to bring travel to
the masses it just makes more money
especially with trains where it cost the
operator roughly the same to transport
five passengers as it does to transport
500 the operator
always
to have as many seats as possible filled
even if that means selling cheap tickets
in a perfect world for the operator they
could ask every potential passenger with
a maximum amount they'd be willing to
pay for the journey is if they adapt the
ticket price to every passengers maximum
price then they can fill each seat with
passengers paying the highest possible
amount however in practice
nobody would ever answer the question
truthfully so it would never work
ticketing systems however try to ask
this question subliminally going back to
that route from an burrow to London the
operator Virgin Trains eastcoast
sells three types of tickets advance
off-peak and any time the advance
tickets range anywhere from 30 pounds to
140 pounds the off-peak fares cost 137
pounds and the anytime fares cost 148
and a half pounds for the advance fares
there are a certain unknown number of
tickets at different price levels on
sale and once they're gone they're gone
for example there might be 15 tickets at
30 pounds and once they're sold the
price increases to 35 then 40 45 and so
on and so forth that encourages those
who can buy early to buy early normally
that means tourists tourists tend to
plan far in advance and are more budget
conscious since they're paying for their
own costs they're also more likely to
travel down to London on the often
cheaper plane since they're less
attracted by the convenience of the
Train these advance fares are only valid
for the exact route day and time bought
which is fine for leisure travellers but
business travellers typically want more
flexibility buying advance fares often
doesn't work for business travellers
since their plans are only made a few
weeks or days in advance and since they
don't personally pay for their tickets
it's no problem for them to pay for the
convenience of taking the train on a
flexible ticket that's why they often
pay 148 and a half pounds for an anytime
ticket with these you can just hop on a
train whenever it doesn't matter if it's
in 10 minutes or 10 days you just step
on the train and take a seat the middle
ground between those two is the off-peak
single which lets you take any train
that arrives in London after 11:17 a.m.
or is on the weekends these fares are
still geared towards your business
by restricting against the early morning
trains they give a discount for those
who can avoid the busiest morning trains
for each of these fairs there are
equivalents in first-class on top of
that young disabled and elderly people
get up to 1/3 off their fares with a
rail card that all means that there are
essentially 12 different types of
tickets for sale and that one person
heading to London might be paying 20
pounds while the person sitting right
next to them is paying 200 or what
they're really paying for is convenience
now back in the US if Amtrak only
operated profitable routes their route
map would look like this
but the routes that don't make money are
the ones that really matter
Amtrak serves over 500 destinations in
46 states many which are small towns
with no other means of public
transportation while trains are normally
the more expensive means of transport
they are less expensive than planes to
service small communities the small
airports in the rural parts of America
are extraordinarily expensive to operate
even if there are just two or three
flights a day they still need a runway
terminal security and air traffic
control while a rural train station
needs barely any infrastructure or
maintenance in fact it's cheaper to fly
from Chicago to London than it is to fly
from half Montana to Chicago
whereas Amtrak brings passengers from
Havre to Chicago for only a few hundred
dollars much more in budget for the
average resident of havoc who makes only
$22,000 per year of course this is a
political issue but a part of why trains
are so expensive is to allow train
operators to fulfill obligations to
serve small communities who need solid
transport links research has shown that
ease of access to transport has a
stronger influence on whether someone
will earn more than their parents did
then the level of crime in their area or
whether they grew up in a two-parent
household and so keeping trains running
through rural America is incredibly
important next time you take the train
from DC to New York just keep in mind
that that $22 and 86 cents of profit
goes to making sure that someone from
Havre can get to Chicago for less than
you can fly to Europe
so you see this number that's how much
these last few seconds would cost if I
were buying footage from a traditional
stock footage provider luckily I get my
footage from video blocks where with
their membership you can use as many of
the 115,000 clips in their unlimited
library as you want since I started
Wendover productions I've used 686 clips
from video blocks almost every piece of
footage you see in my videos is from
them and that means I've saved fifty
four thousand one hundred and ninety
four dollars with my video block
subscription without video blocks
there's no way that my videos would look
as professional I simply would not be
able to afford it and whether you
already have a youtube channel or plan
to start one video blocks will do
amazing things for your production value
I can honestly say that it's one of the
best purchases I've ever made and I've
used video blogs since day one you can
try out video blocks exclusively for
seven days with the linked video blocks
comm slash future that is not a publicly
available trial so please go try them
out not only is that a great way to help
whenever productions make more videos
you'll also get a chance to use what is
truly an amazing service you can also
support Wendover productions on patreon
here follow me on twitter at one of our
pro watch my last video here check out
my fan moderated subreddit here and
lastly subscribe to this channel by
clicking here thanks again for watching
and I'll see you in two weeks for
another Wendover productions video